ich gebe damals diesen Speed Effekt
Leute
[Musik]
wie schnell du dann von hier zum Portal
kommst oder so ich gebe dir jetzt den
Speed Effekt und jetzt lauft man
Richtung Portal
komm mal wieder hoch
[Musik]
ist tot kleiner Hund also ich mache das
jetzt bei mir einmal für 20 Sekunden
drück einmal drauf wo bist du ich will
das zu Hause sehen hier schau nach vorne
nein
oh mein Gott ich bin fast gestorben
irgendwie immer total viele dass ich für
die singe ne wir haben ein Like äh Jungs
[Musik]
junge verteidige mich doch
Sandra lauf doch ey warum bleibst du
denn stehen du Idiot
es kann sein dass es so keine
überleben es kann nicht sein dass ich
bei jedem sterbe es kann nicht sein es
ist egal
gibt's gibt's bei Minecraft so ein
Anfängerkurs kann man den privaten
buchen kannst du mal mit Basti kannst du
den Namen Anschreiben über Instagram das
ist so der beste Minecraft Spieler in
Deutschland würde ich sagen hey Basti
ich bin ultra schlechte Minecraft kannst
du mir mal eine Nachhilfe Stunde geben
Mist okay lass mal so ein Länder Ding
Spiel spielen wir sagen nach und nach
Ländern wer weniger weiß okay
Deutschland
Österreich Schweiz
England
Norwegen ein paar Sekunden später
[Musik]
die ganze Zeit einfach auf den Chat das
ist unfassbar mein Chat ist rechts ich
schwöre es dir
dreh dich weg von deinem Tisch danach
pack dein Handy weg das ist weg ich habe
es vorhin noch gesehen
bist
dein Handy zu gucken
weg ich gucke nicht ja okay hör auf
auf jeden Fall aber wenn die Schummel
der macht keinen Spaß ich gucke nicht
ich bin so schlau
ich hüpfe die ganze Zeit wo bist du hier
oben
die ganze Zeit was ist das
lauf mal weiter jetzt nicht mehr
ich wünschte ich könnte sagen hast du
schon wieder ein Fluch aufgesetzt ich
wünschte ich könnte sagen es war ein
prank aber was einfach nicht nein
oh mein Gott jetzt habe ich es auch
hä
ist irgendein Server bei mir ist es
nicht drüber einfach die ganze Zeit
lass mal beide vom Server runter gehen
vielleicht geht's dann weg warte mal ich
gehe wieder drauf
[Musik]
bei mir geht's wieder
immer noch ne
wie kann das denn sein Hände hoch
dann geht's aber wenn ich wieder auf Weg
gehe dann hüpfe ich
also es geht wenn du beide Hände hoch
nimmst ja
komisch
also hältst du nicht die ganze Zeit
Leertaste gut also
sicher ja Luca weißt du warum ich
gesprungen bin war mein Teller ganze
Zeit auf Leerzeichen
ich lasse jetzt einfach mal laufen mal
schauen gefunden Eisen Eisen okay ja ich
komme hoch
das Eisen
neeisen scheiße
noch
einmal Luca alter dicker
alles geholt
Alter also wie kann man sich so Bee
Eisen freuen unser Projekt so am Arsch
wir leben so ein Minimum wo ist sie
hier viele Augen boah ist die Höhle
riesig viele Monster
bitte die Kohle ab ich töte mal eben ein
paar okay okay
wo ist Eisen Leute
oh ich höre auch schon wieder
müssen eigentlich direkt die Betten hier
setzen ne Luke abgeschossen
habe in der Sekunde benutzt und Tod
warum machen wir ihr denn Schild wenn
Sie es einfach nicht benutzt ein
bisschen
und sicher schon mal ein paar Sachen
soll ich das auch machen
[Musik]
hey halt dein Maul
niemals zurück Handy
ich habe hier rechts weg gemacht mit
einer Kiste die ist weg
ja ich würde sagen dass wir hier das
ganze mal beenden oder im nächsten
Minecraft Stream ich weiß nicht wann wir
wieder online gehen
am besten wirklich einfach folgen hier
auf auf Twitch da ist ja kostenlos dann
kriegt ihr Benachrichtigung wenn wir
online gehen also alle mal wieder auf
Folgen klicken da werden wir uns das
dann hier alles ein bisschen genauer
anschauen werden schauen dass wir
Diamanten finden ein bisschen Eisen und
dann wird die nächste der nächste
Livestream komplett erhöhlen Stream
könnt euch schon auf jeden Fall sehr
darauf freuen ansonsten würden Sandra
und ich an der Stelle jetzt in Minecraft
loser beenden okay Luca es geht denn
jetzt mal offline ne hier von Minecraft
und stelle dann jetzt mal Mario Party 1
[Musik]